[Music]
this is star talk cosmic queries edition
and today's subject is
extremophiles
and alien worlds one of my favorite
subjects chuck what do you think about
that topic uh it kind of sounds like
aliens gone wild
[Laughter]
call right now it's aliens gone wild
you've never seen aliens like this
before
extremophiles
i love me this little bit of this
subject and but we have a one of the
world's experts on it on star talk today
kendall lynch kenda welcome to star talk
thank you so much uh thanks for having
me i'm so excited to be here excellent
excellent you you have a phd
in this stuff and but let me just alert
people that your expertise is is some
kind of amalgam
of whole fields that were previously
distinct from one another because i
think of geology and i think of biology
and i think of modern astrophysics and
you just took a big fat stapler and
crammed them together and then you and
you do all three of these all at once
how is that even possible
um it's called astrobiology
[Laughter]
no but you've got to know your geology
too right um you do have to know yeah i
mean so yeah it's kind of this
interesting thing where you just got to
learn to wear a lot of hats and um and
you don't necessarily you should have i
mean ultimately you have expertise in
one thing a little bit more than the
other but you have to know enough about
the others to kind of pull those pieces
in because ultimately they all are
really interconnected
and you also have to know when you don't
know something and pulling the right
people to work with you but you have to
be able to speak their language so
having that understanding of geology so
i can talk to a hard rock geologist
about you know how i think my bugs are
eating their rock you know it's
important to be able to have the same
you know same conversation about it
let me tell you something this is why i
love being on this show
it's the only time you will ever hear
somebody say and i have to talk to them
about how their bugs are eating my rocks
it's they're just
did i see that sentence coming i did not
but kenda you work on earth so why what
does that have anything to do
with aliens on other world
well i mean the reality is is when we're
trying to understand life in the
universe right now we only have one data
point and that's earth so um
you know we have to kind of work on
earth and try to understand life here
and and really when we think about it
it's a big question how did life even
come to be on earth how did light earth
come to be this big cradle where there's
lots of life just kind of crawling all
over it in it and everywhere
let me let me help you with that kenda
uh
bugs started eating rocks
chuck is not going to shake that
sentence for the next five years
[Laughter]
but when we but when we really try to
understand looking for life in the
universe you know a logical first
question and and especially since we've
tried and and hadn't been too
successful in the past looking for life
on other planets was well how do we how
well do we understand life here on earth
do we understand the extent of where
life can live on earth do we understand
how life arose on earth and kind of what
did early life look like on earth and
and you know where can we go to look for
it and what kind of environments did it
live in those okay i'm an old man here
when i learned about this it was we need
the 72 degree tide pool for for life to
thrive on earth
of the things that we have life is not
comfortable unless it's room temperature
uh yeah i know and it needs just the
right amount of sugars and it needs and
it needs this special kind of media no
every once in a while every once in a
while life is just like who touched that
thermostat
exactly right now which one of y'all
touched that thermostat on its barco
lounger
that would that would be that would be
us as the life we're the ones that kind
of need to we need we are the ones that
glamp right right but microbial life man
every time we think we got those bugs
figured out they do something crazy and
we're like wait what do you mean you can
live on a nuclear reactor wait what do
you mean you can live two kilometers
down in a subsurface in the subsurface
and we find you when we're mining for
gold what do you mean
you live
in like
like super hot water that's also salty
and acidic what do you mean
okay wait a minute three sentences ago
you used the word glam could you please
for anyone over 50 could you just tell
people what that word means please
that's like it's like camping but
glamour camping like bringing your house
with you camping so you maybe have like
you're not really camping you're in the
wild but not really because maybe you
like you also get a
house trailer with you and that's your
camper if you can still watch hbo in
your trailer you're not camping is that
right basically
basically you know if you've got yeah if
you've got a hot tub
and you've got your and you've got and
you've got your your um your keurig or
your tossimo or your what's the other
one you got that making your coffee
you're not camping that's why i camp at
the ritz carlton there you go
okay so you're a staff scientist at the
at the story lunar and planetary science
institute um is that right is that no
just lunar and planetary institute is
that what they call the planetary
institute correct yeah right right and
um that's based in houston houston texas
and we're especially interested in you
today because you um you're featured in
episode two
of netflix's
docu-series alien world
yes so um
pick up the action for us where where do
we find you um you find me
as far as in the episode yeah right when
we open up right in the beginning you
see this alien landscape that kind of
looks to my opinion it looks like mars
but we're actually in the uh dalal
hydrothermal system which is in the
danical depression in ethiopia so
hydrothermal this would be heat emerging
from earth's crust
manifesting
on the surface somehow right yeah
hydrothermal meaning that it's um it's
heat coming from the um from the the
earth's subsurface and in this case a
hydrothermal system usually meets heat
generated waters like geo-generated um
water manifesting up in the surface so
there's water flowing in the subsurface
passing over usually like um what we
call a magma pocket which is a big
pocket of lava and there's water flowing
over it getting super heated and then
pushing up to the earth's surface and
boiling out and spewing out all these
hot gases and everything like that so at
those high temperatures does it absorb a
lot of minerals from the rocks that it
passes through it does it absorbs a lot
of minerals so there's a lot of um what
we call um
anions and cannons there's a lot of
dissolved constituents um chemical
constituents and especially in the dalal
system it also goes through a subsurface
salt deposit so not only is it getting
minerals from like the the from just
like the the ground the subsurface rock
like over the magma pocket pocket but
it's also picking up all these minerals
and dissolving all these salt minerals
and so
dalal
is amazing because it is it's
hydrothermal really hot
and super psychic salty hyper saline
and it's also acidic because there's
also all this iron and sulfur that make
it super acidic that's where you want to
find life
yeah
it's what we call a poly extreme
environment and it's so amazing and it's
a it's a crazy challenge for life and
yet
um you know there's multiple teams of us
working there that are finding evidence
for life
so so the dead sea which is a highly
selenic body of water
could only have been named that by
people who did not have access to a
microscope
yeah because there's a lot of life in
the dead sea
kind of get the feeling that the dead
sea was named because somebody drank it
and then everybody else was like
you see what happened
everybody
don't you see what just happened
there you go
water water all around and not a drop to
drink yeah yeah yeah
so tell me about that i read something
about there's an algae pool nearby or in
some other parts of your work what's
going on there well so it's not really
pools of algae so we have these bubbling
pools right and they're literally like
you literally have elemental sulfur
precipitating out of these waters and
you can see sulfur so it stinks oh it
stick it stinks and it's like
talk you think the dead sea is deadly oh
no dallas deadly you'll see when we're
walking through there you literally see
if you get too close on the ground
there's so much
um hydrogen sulfide gas and carbon
dioxide yes
tell chuck what hydrogen sulfide gas
smells like
um rotten rotting eggs
no you can he's a comedian you can do
better i knew i know
and i'm sitting here
i'm sitting here holding himself
you have no idea the amount of restraint
i just exercised
i have 15 fart jokes right now
that are
bubbling up in me
that's the wrong way to talk about fart
joke
but the chunk of the
fart just backed up in the whole time
you're talking about this and
i was ready to explode with fart jokes
this is all i'm saying
all right you know
okay so how do you do sulfite h2so4 is
that correct uh h2 h2s oh just h2s oh
it's sulfuric acid yeah this and that's
what's in the water is the h2s the
sulfuric acid is actually there's h2s
low uh molarity so i mean well i don't
know i haven't touched the water but in
other acidic environments usually the
h2s is kind of low molarity because i've
also worked in the rio tinto
acid river system and so the h2s is
pretty low like it's not going to like
immediately burn your skin off you know
you'll get a nice peel okay so that's
the place if you're going to eat beans
no one will blame you for anything yeah
not at all yeah total the whole
landscape to blame it on right okay
i would
[Laughter]
where did you grow up um i grew up in
i'm a midwestern kid i grew up in a town
called rockford illinois which is just
west of chicago about 90. about 90 miles
i went into chicago a lot a lot for you
know going to see shows but just to be
clear if you were just 90 miles west of
new york city you were across new jersey
into pennsylvania so
to to index your location
to be 90 miles in any direction from
chicago um does that mean there's no
other big city you can tell us what
you're near
um
no no not where i am because i'm gonna
say if i was east i could say you know
detroit detroit detroit all right
east of chicago but i'm west so no it's
kind of it's kind of open plains and
corn fields and stuff right north of me
though is green bay if i had straight
north you you'd be in great bay we've
all heard of green bay so
well i'm a bears fan so you know let's
not go there oh yeah
the bears so how did you uh so uh how do
you land on extremophiles as a career
goal
oh well you know um this is interesting
because i had a different hat on when i
started my career i actually started
learning how to try to grow food and
keep astronauts alive in
uh in habitats um on other planets
that's cool both of these started out
i started out as a systems engineer on
working on space station and trying to
keep people alive but in my education
i
do i i was i'm nuts and i um did a dual
degree i literally have two bachelor's
degree one interviewing biology but
generally if you're nuts you don't have
to tell that to other people because
it's just completely clear it is true
by the way all you have to do is say i
got two bachelor degrees at the same
time and people
go
you must be nuts
[Laughter]
and
and so part of yeah so yeah well yeah
um and i like pain apparently so you
know there's that um part of it part of
my training was to also learn about
microbes because when growing trying to
grow plants and develop earth microcosms
you know microcosms you have to
understand you know not only how humans
live but how everything else that's
going to interact live so i took classes
in you know aquatic ecology i took
classes in lake ecology i took classes
in plant biology you know and i took
classes in microbiology so at the end of
the day you realize you took two
different majors worth of courses is
that what happened there yep so what are
the two majors what were the two uh the
first one was basically systems
engineering so it was all i took a full
course of engineering classes and then i
took a full course of general biology
classes and um my engineering degree
lets me specialize so i was able to use
a couple of my upper level biology
classes for my specialization in
engineering so so your phd what was the
title of your phd thesis
oh my gosh hang on a second oh my god
like i gotta remember a geobiological
investigation of the hyper sailing
sediments of pilot valley utah a
terrestrial analog to ancient lake
basins on mars
wow okay that's why i had to read it i
couldn't remember i i got to tell you
right now i'm sorry he asked
i retract the question
the funny thing is my phd was still an
engineering degree i unintentionally got
three engineering degrees along the way
i'm liking it all the masters along the
way yeah yeah aerospace engineering for
my master's okay so you were totally
loaded what do you think about since
you're a microbiologist and you were
talking about growing food as one of
your uh tasks when you were working with
space stations what do you think about
matt damon growing poop potatoes on mars
poop potatoes on mars we need we need
the final the final word there he would
have had some problems with his thyroid
because of all the perchlorate in them
and the um
in the regolith so yeah
wow so basically okay we're just going
to make it
i got to unpack that wait a minute wait
a minute so
on earth we have soil
right which is rich in microbes that
participate in the ecosystem
on the moon and on mars there is no soil
whatever the dust is there is like is
ground up rock basically right and so
and you call it regolith
we call it regolith because it has not
been processed by microbes that we know
of
on them like it's definitely not on the
moon and on mars not that we know of and
and we're not sure what the origin is of
the organic matter that we have found so
far mars so
um we call it regolith because it's not
soil like we know it on earth that has
been processed over years by by microbes
and um and other
other life elements and and there's not
a significant amount of organic matter
making it kind of a so he would have had
a thyroid problem so when they picked
him up to save him he basically would
have had a goiter
probably or some other crazy issues his
his his metabolic system would have been
having some weird issues because
perchlorate protect you know actually
kind of competes with iodine to bind on
your thyroid and we know that mars has
an abundance of perchlorate in the
regolith and that's actually something
that um you know i'm working on with
other scientists i'm it's kind of funny
in my astrobiology life i'm starting to
kind of go back to my
to my human space flight routes
and bringing my astrobiology knowledge
and my human spaceflight knowledge
together as we're getting ready to go
back to the moon
well in in the next segment we're going
to pick up questions from our fan base
our patreon fan base chuck has all the
questions i haven't seen them and
we're going to find out what the public
has to ask you and they're very we got a
good we got good people out there listen
to this show they're scientifically
literate and they want to get more
scientifically literate and that's what
this is all about when star talk returns
we're back star talk cosmic queries
we're talking about extremophiles and
alien worlds with one of the world's
experts on that and apparently a whole
lot of other stuff too
we've got kendall lynch
who is a scientist at the lunar
planetary institute in
in houston and who specializes in
[Music]
bugs on earth that do the backstroke in
high temperature high acid high
everything else that would kill us post
haste and we're loving it uh so so kenda
also where where might we find you on
social media
um i am on twitter and i am on facebook
i have an instagram but i need to use it
more but i'm marsgirl42 on twitter for
sure whoa good name cool
it's a good one
and and you can also find me on the lpi
website as well okay the lunar planetary
institute okay very cool and we're gonna
find you in episode two of of alien
worlds uh netflix the netflix
docu-series very cool okay so chuck this
is a cosmic query so we we put out the
call
and so what did you get well we got uh
we've got a bunch of people who actually
um
believe it or not are super interested
in this subject
i believe it i believe it's like weirdly
interesting you know yeah it really is
it really is okay uh let's start off
with our with our favorite uh this is
violetta uh and her mom uh
it says is that y'all growing up by now
because she's in college right now
she she used to write it when she was
like 11 and 12.
when she was 11 and 11 and a half and 12
and 12 and a half okay well here we go
this is uh hi neil hi chuck hi kenda
violetta here they're 13 and a half year
old
she's a full up teenager okay so you
said it neil she did 11 and then 12 12
and a half now she's 13 and a half and a
half all right
okay
she says i'm writing them from
washington d.c and my question is what
is the most surprising fascinating life
form or trait about a life form here on
earth that you have discovered or
learned about in your career so far how
did this impact the way you think about
what life might look like elsewhere in
the universe thanks guys and i just want
to say that dr lynch that the world
needs more scientists that look like you
whoa
by that she means
fabulous
looking fabulous fabulous and she says
thank you so much for doing and being an
inspiration
thank you so much violeta so oh my gosh
there's so many what's the weirdest bug
out there
you got you probably have posters that
rank them
don't tell me that you don't know what
your what your answer is here well i'll
give you my number one favorite because
i just think it's so crazy the thought
of it is just so crazy my great my
favorite bug is um
is the um is the one that can live on
nuclear reactors
and does it have a name
yes and i'm trying to remember it's not
it's not the tardigrade it's not the
tardigrade it's not the tardigrade
because it's a target it's not it's a m
that target is a micro is a small
organism but it's a multicellular
organism it's um
okay but tell us more about it so it can
live like inside a nuclear reactor it
can live on they found it living on a
nuclear action they could take these
high doses of of radiation and it's got
this cool shape it's actually kind of
like a cube almost shape okay in japan
those things turn into godzilla's you
realize
that's how that's how you got all of
those japanese monsters you're talking
about a marble origin story right now
so somebody it's um um
oh yeah the name will come to me and
i'll spit it out at some point later
okay
i know so you like the radiation
resistance of that i just i just think
it's amazing that again it's this whole
thing about every time we think we got
bugs figured out like okay here's their
radiation limit here's their life water
limit here's their cold limit here's the
hot and then bugs are being like yeah no
and they blow us right away
we got this we got this all right so so
is this a this is a single-celled
organism yes this is a single-celled
organic okay yes
whereas the tardigrade is a whole
macroscopic object with legs and
right it's a multicellular organism but
it's still small and it's still
something that has amazing amazing
resilience and and can survive
incredible incredible environments so
i'd be excited if we could find
something like the tardigrade like on
another planet because it definitely has
developed strategies to live in crazy
environments it kind of basically
desiccates itself and like goes dormant
and goes into like a it's like you know
it's they call it a water bear so it
goes into hibernation this really crazy
like dehydrated hibernation and it can
survive all sorts of incr in insane
environments including being exposed to
space oh man there's a whole episode of
star trek discovery devoted to a space
tardigrade that they find that helps
them navigate the mycelium network and
the mycelium cosmic mycelium network is
this thing that allows you to move
faster than light because you enter this
network that kind of transports you
almost instantaneously
to different locations throughout the
universe i love it i love it and they
found it who would have thought
tardigrades were also space-faring well
if they came from space initially right
that's the big thing yeah well cool
let's get the next question chuck what
else you got all righty let's do it
this is
uh nander
nander sirkel
okay that's that's your name now man
here we go
he says i often wonder
when we're looking for life out there
aren't we a bit biased by our own
conditions for life itself like water or
breathable air even when considering
silicon life forms this still assumes
creatures living on planets
do you think it would be reasonable to
consider for example other scales of
life in size
and space time
maybe some life forms would be the size
of planets even galaxy or
quantum particles moving in time so fast
that we as slowpokes can't even see them
whoa
so kendra what part of your phd thesis
dealt with quantum
quantum life forms uh not much of it but
i'll tell you i i was a fan of star trek
next generation so i'm there with this
person's questions you know
but quantum
quantum life forms so not not part of
that but in astrobiology we really do
think about
um what we call as life as we don't know
it
or
what some people like to call weird life
and we try to think when we're looking
for life we try to do we're developing
this way to try to think what we call
agnostically about life which means so
life is we don't know in our real life
so yeah there's the problem we only have
one data point earth and life and life
on earth and even your extremophiles are
part of that one data point yes
everybody even though they're extreme
and they can live on reactors or breathe
iron or you know eat other crazy you
know
metals and things like that rocks
eat rocks yeah and even though they can
do these crazy things they all have
still have the same amino acids as we do
they have the same stereochemistry as we
do and we all have the same fundamental
um basically code we have dna and rna
they all have the same fundamentals we
all have that same base coat of life
that kind of builds the structure of
life so yeah when we think about life on
another planet we have to think about
life as we don't know that what if they
what if they use a completely different
stereo economy what if they use a
different set of amino acids to build
their proteins what if you know what if
they have a different liquid i was just
getting asked this in a previous
conversation about you know what about
titan where we have lakes of methane
it's a fluid and life needs fluid for a
chemistry titan saturn's largest moon
yeah where we've actually been there
yeah yeah and we're sending a beautiful
little helicopter that's going to go and
land and and study on the surface and
those lakes and some of the organic
sands there and try to try to understand
um the possibility for prebiotic
chemistry on titan and that's the
question is is periodic chemistry
possible in you know that kind of
environment and what would it look like
and what could life look like being you
know arising in that kind of environment
one of my favorite new yorker comics was
uh there's a craft flying saucer in the
desert and these two aliens are just
crawling along the sands and one says to
the other ammonia ammonia
i mean that's totally it right i mean
it does i mean on earth it just happened
that water was the thing that was going
to be you know the basis for kemp for
life's chemistry but that doesn't
necessarily mean that that's how it's
going to work on other planets and
that's something that we do have to
think about and we actually have
scientists that study that weird life
and kind of study that chemistry and see
what what could be possible what could
happen so um you know and then thinking
about the larger scale of life we do
have scientists that are you know they
look at things called techno signatures
so we try to understand the scale of you
know uh contacting other
intelligent you know what we call
intelligent i mean forms of life and get
me started on the intelligent comment
you know i don't know yeah we're not
even that yet right
the jury's still out on that joy's still
out on us yeah so yeah exactly
so can i ask both of you this
um is there a finite chemistry in the
universe i know we have the period a
pretty
periodic table
um is there anything that could be
outside of that that could
actually contribute to life that is not
on our periodic table no no no
[Laughter]
everything that we know now there may be
other elements that we haven't
discovered just because we haven't
discovered them yet but no i mean
because all life begins with stars that
you know you know all of our elements
come from stars so
the star stuff that's that's the one
common thing that makes it possible for
us to really think about this question
is the ingredients in the kitchen are
also yeah that's the agreement the
ingredients in the kitchen are the same
across the universe so that's
helpful in fact chuck we do we're doing
better than that because we have created
elements that the universe has never
seen before in our laboratories
so we we created two dozen more elements
or 20 20 yeah about two 20 more elements
than we're currently there so so let me
let me ask you this um kenda
if chemistry is the same
and basically geology is the same
right you put a geologist on a planet
well i know what rock this is or we
might have a different kind of
minerality but it won't be so foreign to
them that they'll be befuddled right is
there any reason and the physics is
obviously the same so if i have the same
physics the same
chemistry the same geology
why can't we think that maybe biology
will go will all focus towards the same
forms as we have here if everything else
does that in the other branches of
science well i mean
that's a that's a loaded question
because it's not
it it's we can expect some of the same
uh principal things to happen like
there's going to be some kind of cell
wall structure there's going to be an
encoding system there's going to be some
way to transfer information there's
going to be some way to move energy and
generate energy there's going to be some
way to move things in and out of an
interior environment those kind of
things yeah we can kind of figure out
that those kind of are the common
elements that are going to make life
happen for biology and those are the
kind of things that we agree that we
agree that we actually kind of agree
there's a common set of of about about
eight things that all life
you know anything we call life will
probably have going on now how they get
it and how they put it together that's
where that chemistry is different and
that's where
the the environmental context that made
the geology is probably different that's
going to matter
and that's where you know you know and
that's where maybe some of the physics
because the gravity is a little
different so some things are slightly
different that help you know drive that
environmental context so i can say that
you're not going to expect life forms
the size of galaxies no we're going to
tell you why i'll tell you why okay
okay so again our galaxy is a hundred
thousand light years across
okay a hundred thousand
if that were a life form
and one part of it had an itch
how long would it take to scratch that
itch
you can't move faster than the speed of
light so so it has an itch and then it
brings one part of it to over to the
other part to scratch it a hundred
thousand years later it scratches the
itch
this is not very effective
this is not a
this is not a coherently functioning
organism right and if evolution requires
a lot of experimenting
then the life form has to be able to
change either on purpose or by accident
fast enough so that you can have enough
of these experiments for it to take on
interesting forms exactly and and if
you're really really big that doesn't
happen so yeah and if it takes a hundred
thousand years to scratch an itch just
imagine how uncomfortable it would be
when its underwear gets stuck in its
butt
okay
i'm more thinking about the size of the
underwear at this point
sorry
just just to be clear i wear boxer
briefs and boxer beats don't get stuck
in your butt oh
look at you sexy
bragging let's see if we can squeeze one
more in before the break all righty
let's do it
here we go this is
akilisha uh
kashyap
man
y'all just messing with me now man that
ain't a real name
okay it's a k h i l e s h
aquiles
kashyap
c k a s h y a p kashyap i hope okay okay
hello doctor tyson b minus on that one
but go on i get an a minus okay a b
minus six oh b damn you just keep i keep
going down before you know it's just
like you're expelled
hello dr tyson hello dr lynch and lord
nice oh okay uh i'm i'm a first-time
patreon member nice and my question is
if we discover life on a restricted body
like europa or enceladus are we allowed
to study them only through orbiting
satellites or can we bring something
back home
and cut them open for science of course
i mean you went dark there you went dark
at the end bro
okay
you started off with uh to real good
you started off with our continuing
mission
[Laughter]
new life new civilizations and then you
ended up with let's just cut these
suckers open
well well be careful there's some folks
around where kendra hangs out in texas
where can we bring it back and barbecue
it
[Laughter]
yeah
we will get to that answer
after the break on star talk cosmic
queries with astrobiologists kendall
lynch
we're back for the third and final
segment of star talk cosmic queries
kendall lynch is with us
there's an expert in microbes on earth
as possible analogs to microbes in the
universe so so
kenda over the break you uh you
remembered this
this
radioactivity loving microbe the name of
it what's it called yes it's called
dinococcus radiodurans and they love
they literally can live on um they found
them on nuclear reactors and they are
very um dinococcus
dino caucus radio durant this sounds
like a rock group it does but doesn't it
it really does you know
chicago
are you ready
[Laughter]
dinococcus
[Laughter]
okay so we left off with a question
about what was it chuck
so uh he wants to know that if we
discover life on a res
a restricted body like europa or
enceladus it's protected by nasa law
basically right so
you know
can we actually study it just through
satellite
orbiting or can we bring back something
and cut it open
[Laughter]
well i mean um
you know to cut it open wow uh so let me
just back up for a second so nasa has a
department of planetary protection and
there there's there's there's a there's
a code within them which is
not a computer code but a behavioral
code whereas they're the selected
objects in the solar system that may
have life
we don't mess with them or if we do we
go in a highly sterilized way and if we
bring anything back to earth we want to
keep that quarantine to make sure it
doesn't kill us that's their job yeah
and that's that's the planetary
protection office and the answer is
we're moving into this phase of science
where we are trying to bring things back
because we realize that we need to bring
things back to be able to study them
better to understand if there's life in
them or not right now we're in the
process with the perseverance rover in
the um in jezreel crater for the mars
2020 mission they're cashing samples
that we're going to send a lander to go
and pick up those samples and hand them
off from the rover and we're going to
bring those samples back to earth from
mars and we actually are have missions
that are being developed to go to try to
land on both europa and enceladus and
enceladus is my favorite it's one of my
favorite icy moons by the way i love
enceladus um to try to understand um to
look at the surface and maybe eventually
try to get a sample a sample that that
came up from the subsurface ocean on
both of those planets
you know that we can we can study and
see to and maybe someday we can figure
out how to bring those back but right
now the goal is to just try to get to
land on the surface and try to study
samples in situ to see if we can find
evidence for
for possible um bio signatures of life
so i may be mistaken with this question
but i'm just going to ask it
did did we not learn from what madam
saturn with karen carolyn porco that
they're going to try to fly something
through
one of the plumes of enceladus and maybe
collect what's being you know pushed out
of the uh the ice yeah we have a we have
a mission that's going to try to do that
i um well we also have uh europa clipper
that's going back to europa um that's
gonna that's gonna that might even be
able to do that with the upper clipper
but we're also trying to fly through the
plumes of enceladus we have the
enceladus orbi lander concept that is
looking at doing that like orbiting but
also sending a lander down to the
surface to pick up to to do some nc2
science on the surface of enceladus
hopefully near one of the tiger claws
where all the stuff is spewing out okay
so that's that's the third time you said
in sichu
[Laughter]
excuse me madame latin there
sorry but that's all science especially
biology we like we like throwing lot
around latin just give me something that
name everything has a latin name in
biology yeah yeah it's latin so so let
me emphasize something that i think you
you said but just wafted by it
the the ice on europa is very thick but
it also cracks and then water seeps up
in the cracks and re-freezes so you're
going to be
you're going to be um astrophysically
lazy and instead of trying to dig
through the ice you're going to try to
see if there's anything that came up
through the ice and froze there it
requires no digging at all right
yeah i mean there's um it might require
some digging for the you know the
subsurface but there are and you know we
have some really brilliant scientists
not me um but some of my colleagues that
are really brilliant that studies other
brilliant scientists yes uh the science
uh
other brilliant scientists not me
because i don't study ice dynamics i'm a
you know i'm the biology one but they
study kind of that geology of those
isomamics and they found that that there
is likely water that is seeping up from
the ocean and and kind of connecting in
the shallow subsurface and and doing
things that they can actually see on the
surface from remote sensing and if that
water below the surface had life it
would have gurgled up and frozen in
place you have freeze-dried life to
study yeah exactly if we can access some
of those areas where that life probably
kind of gurgled up and then enceladus of
course we've got you know the tiger
claws just spewing you know stuff out
into space so we can try to capture some
of that and then we can land on the
surface to try to see what we can see
that maybe kind of fell back down okay
so how sterilized do your probes have to
be to land on a protected body oh very
sterile
that's the challenge of doing this
is that yeah you've got to make sure not
only that the lander is very sterile but
that um that you know all the
instruments that you're working on are
various everything
everything and there are there even a
coronavirus found on
yeah
make the lander wear a mask
just like make sure you wear your mask
lander and use hand sanitizer use hand
sanitizer and show us your vax card
before you touch that
all right chuck give me another one
another question chef all right all
right before you know what i got to ask
this just before we go i know i'm not a
patreon
but so when you talk about this water
underneath this basically you know this
planet uh you got the ice like a crust
and then the water underneath but then
you have other bodies in space that are
just
frozen
solid pieces of water
why doesn't the planet
just freeze all the way down why is
there water underneath that ice that
means
yeah on the moon it's not the planet i'm
sorry yeah why do why do we have these
ocean worlds on moons around one moon
yes well first of all a couple of
different things first first of all um
there is we get heating from the gravity
the extreme gravity that causes what we
call tidal heating and and um and neil
can probably explain that better that
that kind of pushes and flexes and
causes heating that kind of adds some
heating to the planet and keeps it warm
plus these waters have lots and lots and
lots and lots of salt
lots of salt that are keeping that are
depressing the freezing the the the
freezing point so the salt the water is
able to stay liquid because there's so
much salt in it that that freezing pot
gets lowered because there's so much
salt in it keeping it liquid
it's been rumored that zero on the
fahrenheit scale
is the freezing temperature of a
supersaturated solution of
brine of salt water it's been rumored um
and
so that's we get a zero
that's the coldest liquid they could get
that would freeze and then regular water
just goes freezes at the warmth of 32
degrees on the fahrenheit scale but yeah
no you said it perfectly uh canada just
the tidal stress between jupiter and the
tugs of other surrounding moons are
pumping energy in and so now it's a heat
source that just has nothing to do with
the sun
i learned in my biology books you need
sunlight for life what you really need
is just energy if you take the physics
angle on you just need energy and you
pump energy in from from tidal forces
you got it right and what they think is
going on in the zeldas is they actually
think that heat is also generating kind
of and maybe it's maybe some residual
heat but probably more of the tidal
forces on enceladus generating heat
that's causing hydrothermal hydrothermal
vents like what we see on earth you know
the deep sea hydrothermal vents with the
black smokers and things that you see
like on the national geographic videos
they think that that's what they're
seeing in the uh in enceladus and that's
kind of what's kind of helping to kind
of possibly generate the tire claws
pushing pushing that energy out and that
is creating a lot of cool chemistry that
life can live that life could take
advantage of so kenda we've had natalie
starkey on the show who
wrote a book recently on uh all the cool
literally and figuratively things in the
universe volcanoes hot and cold and she
describes enceladus as a as an ice
volcano world yeah and the plumes are
just where you just need extra pressure
build up it didn't have to be hot
compared to us
it could just be pressure in its own
environment even if it's very cold so
yeah very cool chuck keep it coming you
can't get better than that uh that's so
cool
cryovolcanism if that doesn't if that
doesn't make you love science you're
dead inside yeah i want that on my
business card exactly i'm a
cryovolcanist yeah what are you okay
all right here we go this is william d.a
thank you william thank you
[Laughter]
he says
given that humans have always been
fighting a war with tiny bacteria
viruses and prions etc
how likely do you think it is that
there's a planet out there with a tiny
microscopic organism
and it wiped out
the more complex life
what would such a planet look like long
term
and uh
that's what you said so if we're in a
war with if we all got killed by a virus
here
then what happens long term even if it's
just here on earth
yeah ultimately do all the little things
kill all the big things and you just
have a planet full of viruses
a or single-celled organisms yeah what
is it where does biology go right in the
liver hey what's up corona what's up
strep cocktails
given that we've already had hey
rhinovirus how you doing today yeah
everybody's just chilling out about
cities and things
get out of here herpes
you weren't invited to the park you know
you got invited man
you know given that we've already had
multiple mass extinction events on the
planet already
um where we've we're like not
necessarily microbes have taken out our
bigger organism but something else
usually an asteroid or something else
took out
our larger
organisms life is just kind of rebounded
and yeah for a while the the little guys
were you know
the little guys were in charge but life
eventually kind of picked back up and
and organisms got more you know there's
there's an advantage on earth for
multicellular
multicellularity and so life eventually
kind of worked its way back to um
multicellularity at some point you know
and those small guys got bigger and
bigger and more complex more complex
each time but we've you know so um oh i
would say is if we had a micro generated
mass extinction event my guess is yeah
for a while the little guys would be in
charge but then eventually
um you know depending on the you know
the environment of earth if it's
advantageous to take advantage of
resources and to keep yourself alive to
become multicellular life would probably
go back to being multicellular or having
a multicellular component on the planet
that's an excellent argument because if
we've done it multiple times in the past
why not again i mean after the kt
extinction nothing bigger than
you know a suitcase or something you
know
squirrels and rats yeah a duffel bag
biggest size life form and now we have
you know the blue whale swim in the
ocean the largest animal there ever was
so
a very good argument there yeah i'm with
you on that that's very cool chuck we
got time for like one more i think what
do you got uh all right let's uh
let's go to kevin the sommelier
kevin says
we'll party with you kevin
exactly
kevin says you know when i'm sitting
around drinking a chateau nerf to pop
but no does
[Laughter]
i wish he did start like that
kevin says astrobiology
used to be termed
exobiology
was this just a rebranding to make
people more interested in it like when
coke introduced new coke
but had to go back to classic coke well
keep drinking up kevin the san manye
that's a very good question that i'm i'm
thinking about here because you know
the reality is is that when i fell in
love with this it was exotic biology
when i was and i'm not going to date
myself but when i got my first lecture
it was from this gentleman named donald
d vincenzi who was a part of what was
called the exobiology office at nasa and
fyi nasa always had an exobiology
offices nasa started with an isobiology
office so this has been a question that
nasa has wanted answered since the
beginning of nasa so this has been kind
of part of our charter from the
beginning and so
i think the big transition came
obviously after the the viking results
but i think the big transition to astro
biology came after
um the allen hills rock and the
discovery of the organics in the allen
hills rock and
you know the the
um
the um
the the hypothesis that these were
organics were made by martian microbes
and these kind of microbes made these
special you know the whole argument
about the biogenicity of the organic
structures in right the allen hills rock
is about the size of a idaho potato been
sitting on the shelf for years
we knew it was a meteorite but no one
really knew much about it until like you
said the viking mission we have accurate
measurements of the atmosphere of mars
from that mission and air pockets
trapped in that rock matched that air
exactly and oh my gosh yeah and rock for
mars sitting on the shelf the age of snc
rocks meteorites was born i never mind
looking ignorant because it's my
specialty
please tell me what the allen hills rock
is the allen hills is a mars meteorite
we know as as neil said that it came
from mars because we look at these
little little bubbles in it that keep
gases in it and we're able to extract
the gas and look at the gas composition
and it tells us it has the exact same
composition of the gases on mars from
our viking results and so we know that
this meteorite was a piece of mars that
got blasted off and traveled to earth
and and kind of landed on earth and so
allen hills is one of what we call an
snc or a mars meteorite that came from
mars
and
just for just for for background there's
a set of hills in antarctica called the
allen hills
where the glacier that is like
permanently on antarctica for now
as it migrates it comes up against the
hills and if any rock fell from space
and landed on this glacier it gets
dragged to these hills and deposited
there so it's it's it's a really
convenient way to scoop up meteorites
without having to comb thousands of
square miles of area you let the glacier
do it for you so it's in allen hills um
and was found in 1984. wow so yeah and
they still do and they do still do
annual trips um or they have been i
don't know if they stopped because of
covert for a while to antarctica to look
to go out and look on the glaciers for
meteorites because anywhere else you
actually have to watch it fall to kind
of go look for it or you have to you
know and we've had we have people send
us rocks especially at the lpi all the
time i think it's a meteorite and it's
not oh yeah it's here we call the meteor
wrongs yeah exactly their media are
wrong
is it most certainly possibly as much as
half of all meteorites
in our collections come from these ice
sheets and people wonder what did the
eight meteorite the
meteors aim for the ice sheets no that's
the only place you would find them if
they fell otherwise you have to sift
through countless other rocks in the
forest you know which one came from
space and which didn't and most of the
ones that are verified that weren't
felon on the glacier is because somebody
watched it fall and trapped yeah exactly
so but the point the point is is that
after you know we got allen hills and
this was back in uh
92 93 is that right um when they the
study came out and they thought that
this happened and everybody you know
kind of disagreed and we had you know
arguments back and forth about are they
life are they not life and then we
realized do we really understand what
life is and this is about the time that
we started learning about and we started
learning more about extremophiles and
the rna world
the vastness of the rna world and we
started learning more about
biotechnology and our capabilities for
um you know for you know higher sample
resolution and sample um
and sample detectability um
uh you know in our instruments got
higher so all of this kind of stuff made
us start to question i mean instruments
got more sensitive yeah yes thank you
more sensitive
can't find my words today
that's fine okay
um but um all of these things kind of
together kind of you know with that
allen hill's discovery and at that time
they went back and looked at the viking
results and and realized that viking
would not have necessarily caught
everything because of the
the sensitivity wasn't high enough right
so there's all of these things going on
um you know we started asking the
question like what do we really know
about life do we really understand life
on earth do we really understand the
extent of life or what is alive on earth
and so that's where
astrobiology because it was looking
exobiology was like looking for life
elsewhere but astrobiology includes
understanding how life on earth also
came to be how did we become to be a
living planet so that's where the new
term astrobiology came from because it
became about looking for life on earth
looking for life in the universe but
also trying to understand how do we
become the data point that we have now
how do we become to be here yeah so i
take the meta view which is everything
the astrophysicist does in space has a
counterpart here on earth and so you
want to glue together astro in front of
each of those words so we have
astrochemistry astrobiology astral
particle physics and so astro
with a push cart for it all i just
wanted right there you go
yeah i like that one too
funny how the astrophysicists become the
quarterback of the team
[Laughter]
so kenda i remember when
that allen hills rock made news and it
was a research paper by some folks at
johnson space center making the claim
that maybe this has evidence for life
which meant life was on mars i remember
it like it was yesterday and
there was some chemistry within the rock
and then there was a there's a photo of
the a worm looking thing
on the surface
and
we didn't know what it was it was really
tiny
but it was just kind of intriguing it
made a good headline photo but the
better evidence was from the other
chemistry going on in the rock i was on
a talk show
to comment on this rock and they had me
a philosopher
and a biologist
and the philosopher said how do we know
whether the rock itself is not alive
okay we got that out of the way okay
we've got to make that comment stop
smoking weed dude
we have to get past that and then
so then they put up the photo of this
worm thing and the biologist says that
can't possibly be life
and i'm thinking wow
the biologist must know a lot to know
that that can't be so i said well how
come
and he says oh because that's one tenth
the size of the smallest microbes on
earth and i then said
last i checked
this is from mars
it was like and i realized
how narrow the thinking was of
biologists
because like you began this program
kenda if you if all you have is a data
sample of one
you have no capacity to think
differently
everything has to be shoehorned into
your own understanding of the world and
i was perfectly happy to have it be a
life form that we don't know anything
about
deal with it and that biologist today is
working at mcdonald's
[Laughter]
i don't remember who that was but i
don't know probably not we got to call
it quits there uh kenner has been
delight to have you on the show i
remember you when you were in graduate
school you're all grown up now
she's all grown up
such an honor to be here and i'm so glad
that you remember me actually we finally
found you in the ether
and
uh we can find you on netflix uh episode
2 of alienworld and we're loving it and
chuck always good to have you there my
co-host always a pleasure all right neil
degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
you